les français ont-ils pris trop tôt leurs
désirs pour une réalité c'est ce que
laisse à penser en tout cas ce matin les
russes qui réagissent à l'annoncé de
l'elysée l'année dernière l'entourage
des manuels macron se féliciter d'avoir
convaincu joe biden et vladimir poutine
de se rencontrer à l'occasion d'un
sommet ce qui serait loin d'être le cas
en croire ces dernières réactions du
kremlin on va retrouver tout de suite
notre correspondante en russie elena
volochine hélèna bonjour le kremlin qui
a donc réagi et qui indique qu'il n'y a
pour le moment aucun projet concret de
rencontre vladimir poutine et emmanuel
macron ont convenu effectivement de
poursuivre le dialogue mais via
seulement leur ministère des affaires
étrangères et leurs conseillers
diplomatiques c'est ce qu'indique un ce
dernier communiqué que faut-il
comprendre derrière ces propos derrière
ces mots
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
vladimir poutine veut absolument
maintenir le bras de fer il
effectivement il y avait ce communiqué
de l'elysée qui disait que vladimir
poutine serait tombé d'accord avec une
rencontre de joe biden est donc à moscou
on se demandait pourquoi il n'y avait
rien du côté du kremlin et c'est parce
que vladimir poutine ne veux pas aller
trop vite pourquoi parce que c'est trois
principales revendications vis-à-vis des
etats-unis et de l'otan n'ont pas été
entendus et le communiqué du kremlin qui
lui fait état de pertes mans discussion
téléphonique d'hier avec le président
français manuel macron ce communiqué il
dit que vladimir poutine que le kremlin
veut être entendu sur ces trois points
ils sont irrecevables j'ai des
occidentaux il s'agirait de nevers le
temps de revenir de faire revenir l'otan
en europe à ses positions de 1997 est à
dire retirer les troupes de l'alliance
de 13 pays européens
et là-dessus bladimir poutine pour le
moment semble intransigeant
même s'il semble prêt au dialogue parce
que s'il ne confirme pas une possible
rencontre avec joe biden dans tous les
cas il s'est entretenu hier deux fois
avec le président macron le deuxième
coup de fil a eu à une heure du matin
heure de moscou donc il y a le signe que
vladimir poutine veut dialoguer mais on
ne sait pas encore s'il est prêt à aller
au compromis elana chine voilà pour ces
dernières réactions sur le plan
diplomatique et vous vous trouvez vous
sur le terrain
côté russe évidemment il y a eu aussi
ces dernières réactions un dieu du
kremlin qui se dit inquiet de
l'évolution de la situation qui continue
de faire et 1c sa rhétorique de
provocation de la part de la partie
ukrainienne vladimir poutine va donc
réunir en urgence de façon imminente son
conseil de sécurité elle va s'exprimer
on s'inquiète évidemment de cette de
cette prise de parole de ce qu'il
pourrait annoncer un
oui alors cette histoire dont d'autres
craignent n ce n'est que la partie
immergée de l'iceberg de ce que l'on
voit de là les normes propagande qui est
déployé ici côté russe et notamment dans
les territoires séparatistes avec la
terminologie de guerre de cette
propagande qui a été ressortie avec les
mots de génocide avec les mots de nazis
ukrainien qui préparer un génocide
contre cette population on voit ses
pendants temps ces messages partout sur
les chaînes de télévision de l'état
russe sur les chaînes de télévision de
l'aider des républiques séparatistes
aussi qui ont leurs propres médias et
donc la population sur place entend ces
messages nous avons parlé je me trouve
en ce moment dans la région frontalière
avec ce don bas séparatiste où affluent
des milliers de réfugiés depuis ces
régions depuis que l'ordre d'évacuer ps
donné il y a deux jours et ce qu'ils
disent qu'ils craignent effectivement il
ils haïssent le gouvernement ukrainien
pour leur faire la guerre et ils
craignent une nouvelle attaque attaque
mais de l'autre côté et à aucun moment
ils ne pensent que la russie
la liaison extrêmement difficile avec
elena volochine notre envoyé spécial à
taganrog en territoire russe non loin de
la frontière ukrainienne elena qu'on
retrouvera contentera le retrouver
évidemment dans nous dans nos prochaines
éditions